dune 2020 is happening and there has
been an onslaught of new photos of the
movie and the set
and so far everything looks pretty epic
and a whole new wave of excitement has
been ignited for this movie
and the dune series as a whole so before
we get started if you wanted
detailed breakdowns of doing lore check
out my ultimate guide to doing videos
which can be found
in the doom playlist on the front of
this channel so far i've covered the
first five
original frank herbert dune books and
i'm currently working on the final video
in the series
many people are talking about dune right
now which is great because i think it's
one of the greatest and certainly one of
the most
influential science fiction sagas of all
time but dune is also very complicated
not only narratively
but thematically as well so in this
video i will do my very best to break
down some of the key themes of the
series
first however we will have to briefly
talk about the setting of the dune
universe
and its social and political structure
alright so dune takes place in the year
101
90 ag this is about 20 000 years in our
future
the epoch ag stands for after guild the
guild is significant enough to be used
as a marker of time because the guild
provided the means for safe
faster than light travel between worlds
which effectively unify at the imperium
you've probably heard that the dune
universe runs on a substance called
spice
that is true the planet iraq is also
known as dune is the only planet in the
known universe
where the spice melange can be found the
spice is a substance that extends life
heightens awareness and in some it can
lead to prescient vision
and it is also essential to space travel
oh and one last thing the spice is
highly addictive to the point that once
you become addicted you must continue
taking it otherwise the withdrawals will
kill you
moving on the empire is maintained by a
balance of power between the emperor the
noble great houses of the lamb's rad
the spacing guild and the highly
secretive highly manipulative
ever adapting benny jesuit sisterhood
the benny jesuit sisterhood are key to
the essential plot lines of dune
for thousands of years they've been
attempting to create the quizets had
iraq
the quizzes had a wreck would be a man
trained in their ways
possessing of all their powers and more
but ultimately their plans are thrown
off when the benny jesuit lady jessica
who was given the task of bearing only
daughters to the duke of tradies
chose to give birth to a son instead
jessica trained her son paul in the bini
jesuit way
the result was quizets hadirak born a
generation too soon
paul was not bound under benny jesuit
conditioning
they could not control him inadvertently
through their own hubris they unleashed
a super being unto the universe
and the eventual results would be
devastating and long lasting
alright so now that we've gotten all
that out of the way it's time to get to
the main topic of this video
what are the key themes of the dune saga
the major theme that i have mentioned
multiple times on this channel and will
continue to drive home is that all
leadership should be questioned
everything else in the saga is woven
around this idea
this theme isn't as obvious in the first
book as it is in the later books of the
series
in book one paul does however glimpse
the jihad
he sees what his leadership of the
freeman eventually leads to
the death and devastation that is caused
to survive in the desert paul and
jessica called upon the sisterhood's
missionary protectiva
myths and legends had been planted on
the planet by the benny desert centuries
ago in order to prepare the universe
for the coming of the quizets hatarak it
was one of the ways that the sisterhood
manipulated the people of the imperium
knowing this paul and jessica used these
myths to convince the fremen that paul
was in fact the freeman's prophesized
savior
and the freemen served even to their own
demise
the price of the survival of house
atreides was the death of 60 billion
people
related to this the benny jesuit
sisterhood sought to control power
beyond
them in the creation of a quizette's
hatarak powers that mankind should not
wield though paul's creation was their
mistake the result of jessica's betrayal
the question of whether or not they
would have been able to control
any quiz at tatarak must be considered
it is clear from the book heretics of
dune that the mother superior of the
sisterhood teraza
fears even the remnants of prescience in
atreides descendants such as o'draid
who still possesses a form of what they
referred to as
the wild talent in my opinion
all of this suggests that the dune saga
can be viewed as arguing
that prescience is a power that no one
should have
this seems the most heavily implied in
the book god emperor
of dune in this novel the goal of lato
ii is
ultimately to destroy the ability of
those endowed with prescient power
to affect the whole of humanity as he
did
in order to undo the damage done by
prescience in the past
lato had to transcend his humanity and
become something more
a god lato made the ultimate sacrifice
doing what his father paul had refused
to do
locking humankind into a future in which
he was doomed to suffer
eons of personal torment and loneliness
as he underwent his metamorphosis for
this he knew he would be remembered as
the tyrant all of this he did to write
the damage done by the sisterhood's
tinkering
and to prevent the future damage that
prescience would cause
i am not a leader nor a guide a god
remember that i am quite different from
leaders and guides
god's need take no responsibility for
anything except
genesis gods accept everything and thus
accept nothing gods must be identifiable
yet remain
anonymous gods do not need a spirit
world
my spirits dwell within me answerable to
my slightest summons
i share with you because it pleases me
to do so what i have learned about them
and through them they are my truth
here lato is clarifying the difference
between a leader or a king and a god
who or what permits lato to do as he
does
to claim godhood and maintain dominion
over the human universe
in the book god emperor of dune this
question is explored on several
occasions
it is best exemplified in one of the god
emperor's conversations with the
character siona
none of this gives you the right to
govern she said
lato suppressed a smile at last they
were down to the root of siona's
rebellion
by what right where is the justice in my
rule
by imposing my rules upon them with the
weight of fish speaker arms
am i being fair to the evolutionary
thrust of humankind
lato's right to rule is key here
he was not elected the people did not
raise him up as their leader
he was a god ruling through tyranny and
oppression
but lato had experienced the whole of
humanity through his other memory and
prescient power
he knew what was to come and what had
come before
in the dune universe the extinction of
humankind is thwarted by a god king
who had a very valuable lesson for them
all of course in the real world
there are no god-kings no one that can
or
should wield that power in our own world
there is no lato the second to teach us
that ultimate lesson so it is up to us
to realize it for ourselves
to sum things up so far we've discussed
some of the key themes involving
leadership
and accepting the limits of human power
and control
tying both of these together are the
ideas presented surrounding fanaticism
and religious engineering
the word fanatic comes from the latin
word meaning furious enthusiastic or
raging
fanaticism refers to behaviors or
beliefs which are characterized by
unquestioning zeal and enthusiasm
to the point of obsession often the word
fanatic is used to refer
to a person obsessively devoted to a
religion
or particular group there are several
examples of fanatical groups in the dune
saga
the freemen who led paul atreides jihad
are the most famous
example but ideas surrounding fanaticism
continue
throughout this series the fish speakers
the all-female servants of the god
emperor lato the second
are probably the best example of a
fanatical group in the whole series
their devotion to their god is without
question
anything they viewed as a slight against
their god emperor was met with the
harshest punishment
they obeyed the god emperor in all
things at his command they would
slaughter innocents by the thousands
or fall on their own blades without
hesitation
the character naila and god emperor of
dune is the best single example of a
fanatic in the whole series
nayla's green eyes on the gilded
cushions of her cheeks stared out at him
without questioning without
comprehension without the need of either
response
if i sent her out to collect the stars
she would go
and she would attempt it she thinks i am
testing her again
i do believe she could anger me this
damnable religion should
end with me later shouted why should i
want to loose a religion upon my people
religions wrecked from within empires
and individuals alike it's all the same
yes lord religions create radicals and
fanatics like you
thank you lord the short-lived
pseudo-rage sank back
out of sight into the depths of his
memories nothing dented the hard surface
of nala's faith
nayla's faith in later would allow her
to accept any paradox
she knew with a certainty that only
fanatics possessed that her god's will
was the first and the last and that
nothing that happened was beyond his
vision
nayla's fanaticism does not end well for
her ultimately the character stillgar
over the first three books
is an excellent example of a fanatic
growing out of their fanaticism
in the book doom stilgar is confident in
paul's godhood
throughout the second book do messiah he
is confused but still certain of it
floating on the edge of realization but
by the book children of dune
he has come to a revelation it was the
religion of muadib
upset stilgar the most why did they make
a god of muadeeb
why deify a man known to be flesh
muadeeb's golden elixir of life had
created a bureaucratic monster which had
satisfied human affairs
government and religion united and
breaking a law became sin
a smell of blasphemy arose like smoke
around any questioning of governmental
edicts
the guilt of rebellion invoked hellfire
and self-righteous judgments
yet it was men who created these
governmental edicts
it takes more than twenty years before
stillgar finally realizes the horror
of what they had done on arrakis the
apotheosis of paul atreides
they had placed the powers of god in the
hands of a man
and he had caused obscene damage with it
before he himself was
ultimately destroyed and witnessing
paul's children
the royal twins lato angonema who are
clearly more powerful
stillgar sees even more potential danger
and even considers killing the twins
stilger however was only able to realize
that paul and his children were flesh
and bone due to his proximity to events
and even then it took decades for his
fanaticism to die
on that same coin are the themes
surrounding religious engineering
as i mentioned before religious
engineering is a form of social
engineering
directly focusing on human beliefs about
spirituality
morals prophecy sacred texts etc
the idea is that once you understand the
ways in which religion can be used to
control and manipulate
groups of people then you can start
doing this on a larger scale
intentionally
which is exactly what the benny jesuit
sisterhood did with their missionary
protactiva
as i mentioned earlier the goal of the
sisterhood's missionary protactiva was
to sew legends and miss
on different planets throughout the
imperium these myths which were
carefully designed by the sisterhood
were intended to prepare the universe
for the eventual quizatrak
which they hoped to create one day
alongside this the sisterhood operated
in the guise of a religious organization
they infiltrated countless groups
throughout the imperium positioning
themselves out of sight
while manipulating everything around
them stilgar's reluctance to let go of
paul's divinity
is a testament to the effectiveness of
the sisterhood's religious seeding
it was the many generations of religious
seeding done by the sisterhood that
would allow for the rise of paul
atreides and his friend legions
and of course later ii built his empire
including the religious framework and
mystique surrounding himself
on the backbone of what they had done
before the point of these ideas about
fanaticism and religious engineering
being present
is this frank herbert wants us to
question the things we believe and
attempt to understand why we believe
them
now if you've been paying attention you
can probably see how this relates to his
ideas about looking critically at our
leaders
human beings are always fallible subject
to change vulnerable to corruption
there is no god emperor no one to
glimpse into the future and figure out
the best path for us
and if such power did exist who could be
trusted with
the responsibility of it how could we
ensure that they would lead us down the
correct path for us all
and not just one which benefited them in
their own well-being
the results like in dune would almost
certainly be devastating
in the real world it is up to us to
prevent kralozak
the mythic battle at the end of time and
the way we do that is by
growing continuing to change and evolve
accepting our differences while at the
same time
coming together as one human organism so
in a nutshell
question your leaders question your
beliefs accept human limits but continue
to grow and never stagnate
and those are just a few of the main
themes of dune there's so many that in
all actuality i'll probably end up
making a part two to this video
dune is absolutely one of the richest
series that i've ever read the
philosophies and concepts that are
explored
are endlessly intriguing and the way
frank herbert presents them is also very
appealing to me personally
and as always with the upcoming
dannyville new dune movie coming out at
the end of the year
there has been a lot of excitement just
the other day brian herbert son of frank
herbert and author of the expanded dune
books tweeted that
we have even more exciting press
releases coming very soon
so stay tuned for that guys i'll of
course be covering all of the dune 2020
news here on this channel
as it comes out so make sure you
subscribe please let me know what you
guys think of all this in the comment
section below
one of the best things about doom fans
is that you guys always leave such
thoughtful comments and i thought a
video like this would be just the thing
to get some deep thoughts going
oh and one more thing for the past
couple of years i've had the privilege
and the wonderful opportunity
to work on a graphic novel called tadia
all the art
in the book is drawn by the incredibly
talented matthew weldon
who it's been an honor to work with the
story itself was written by me
it's a horror story about witches and
you can get put on the mailing list
to be notified as soon as the campaign
launches in less than two months
click on the link in the description
thanks guys special shout out to my top
patrons
trini girl joseph rosner milton
christopher appling
richard hess deus technica juliana ilion
the collier report paula zach glazar
matthew snyder jim nimmith alex butler
and frederick nordland